hello everyone and welcome back to the
second
day of the gold money asian rapid
knockouts it's anish geary versus
vladislav
also known as chuck norris uh why is he
known as chuck norris well
for good reason as you'll see in this
game so anish is in a pretty difficult
situation he lost yesterday and he
didn't just lose he lost by a margin of
three to zero
uh but luckily he doesn't need to win by
a margin of three to zero to bonds back
he just needs to win today's match to
get back into the match and force tie
breaks but at this game
it's really something else you're going
to enjoy it uh let's check it out anish
with the white pieces
uh opens with e4 uh we have c6 artemiev
goes for the karo khan defense we have
d4 d5
and now e5 and is going for the advanced
variation and now
bishop to f5 you want to develop your
light square bishop play e6
and then uh h6 or h5 to create a
and an escape square for this bishop uh
and here anish strikes with h4 this is
known as the tile variation
of the of the advanced carl khan uh we
have h5 now not allowing any g4 h5
action so h5
uh and c4 uh we have e6 now closing the
structure as the bishop has been
developed here
and knight the c3 have d captures on c4
and now bishop capture so helping white
to develop this light square bishop a
little bit
but again for good reason as you'll see
later on so here
knight's the d7 rtm of continuous
development
and knight g to e2 uh we have bishop to
e7
and now g3 first uh kind of defending
that pawn because
you can't castle the h four pawn would
be hanging uh and now
bishop to g4 a slight improvement in the
position uh pinning this knight here
for the moment uh and here there is one
game where queen to d3 was played
just on pinning uh uh so so the knight
can move but here in the game we have
bishop to f4
and it is now as a move tended we have a
completely new game
so let's see how artemiev continues this
here artemis plays knight to h6
and it's not um it's not a kind of move
that when you see it you feel that
there is some imminent danger present
that you have to be aware of
but there is here in this position a
danger
lurks everywhere uh but anish uh
isn't careful and he falls right into it
here anish says all right i'm gonna
unpin now i'm gonna play queen to d3
just continue my development but
this move allows artemief to do
something incredible
uh so feel free to pause the video here
and try to find out
if you are uh as good as chuck norris
here to find such an
incredible move while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those who were able to do it
congratulations on
realizing that the queen on d3 is
undefended uh well not really because
the bishop is defending the queen but
we said that b5 can be played at at just
the right moment to you know
grab uh some advantage for black and
this is
one such position so congratulations to
everyone who found this it's very
very difficult to spot this uh b5 is
what artemis played and now
there's a problem your bishop is under
attack and you really don't have a move
other than bishop to b3 so this is what
aneesh played
and now this knight that would well have
a hard time getting into the game
now comes into the game via knight to c5
and now it cannot be captured because
the queen on d3
really is hanging so here after knight
to c5 you have to move the queen
and then this knight will be exchanged
for this powerful bishop
queen d1 was played uh queen to c2 was
somewhat better but it's very hard to do
no no such things when you're playing
the game uh knight captures on b3
grabbing the bishop a captures and now
b4 dislodging this knight and here
uh white is in a lot of trouble because
if you move the knight let's say
knight's day four then we get
knights to f5 in and now uh you're just
gonna play bishop captures here queen
captures and then eliminated this d4
pawn
and then white's entire position will
just crumble and there's really no good
way to defend this if you try something
like bishop to e3
to try and keep an eye on the pawn then
we get this queen to d5 move in
attacking the rook and after
white castles then comes this move uh we
attacked the bishop here now threatening
to capture and capture and after
let's say the queen defends now we can
even bust through with bishop captures
on h4
and that's it there's no playing this
for white if you accept
uh then it's just bishop captures uh
queen captures knight captures here you
can't capture because the queen hangs
and then knight f3 check is coming rook
is coming into the attack it's just
going to be
very quickly over so instead after b4
anish says all right we can't really
allow this knights to go to f5 and you
know uh
wreak havoc uh so we have to capture it
bishop captures on h6 was played
but now b captures on c3 again anish's
uh
bishop is attacked here so what do you
play here uh bishop to c1 is the
is the safe move but he decides to go
for bishop captures on g7
and now c captures on b2 anisha has to
win today's match in order to to bounce
back so he can't uh or
even go for for a safer move so here c
captures on b2 and now if you trade
rooks which kind of seems like something
you can do you can't if you capture on
h8
then we just play bishop to b4 check we
want to get
rid of the king so the king does not
defend the knight here and now after
king f1 we play queen to d5
first now attacking the rook here and
again
not not much you can do uh if you move
the rook then queen e4 a nicely with a
double attack on the knight here
and of course if you move the king then
we just capture the knight the queen
can't capture because then we bring
another queen into the game
and if you move the queen then we then
we finally grab the rook and after queen
captures well
you're down a piece and uh it's not like
you're down a piece it's like you're
done everything this is
not uh you know coming into the game
anytime soon this bishop
uh also has no way of of entering the
game the queen
not really do you know it's such a such
a silly position to even look at
the the pieces are occupying the corners
of the board
and not not doing anything so you can't
go for that so instead
instead of bishop captures an h8 rook
the b1 was played
but it doesn't help rook g8 attacking
the bishop bishop to f6
and now only now queen to d5 this queen
to d5 was always ended up in in the
position but you
have to wait the right moment to play it
and now was the right time
so if you castle now again queen to f3
just
a double attack on the knight and if we
attack the
if we defend the knight then comes the
bishop the h3 with threat and checkmate
and the only way to prevent checkmate is
knight f4 but we simply don't care we
capture it because the g
pawn is pinned so no no possible way of
defending this
so you can't castle anish plays rook to
h2 he tries to defend like this but now
comes uh
so super sneaky move bishop to a3 he
just defends his past pawn
and he says what do you play here he
says anish look at your position
uh what is this i mean uh
this rook here this rook on h2 the king
and e1 uh
i mean it's such a bad position for
white this is just incredible and it's
only move 19.
so here bishop the g5 was played trying
to get the bishop back into the game
uh but bishop to f5 now attacking that
rook on b1 and here anish played knights
the c3 as the rook really doesn't have
anywhere to go attacking the queen
but now our team have just played bishop
to b4
attacked the knight the knight is now
pinned it cannot move and he was in this
position on move 21 that anihili
resigned the game
and game one of their second match goes
to the incredible vladislav
who did not only beat giri in 21 moves
with
the black pieces but this is also his
fourth win in a row against aneesh so
for four to zero that's
incredible uh artemia really crushing
this uh this tournament
and he will definitely be a force to
reckon with anish can still bounce back
but uh four to zero i mean that's hard
hard to play against uh so yeah here you
resign there's no way to defend the
knight you're gonna lose it
if you move the queen to defend it uh we
don't really care we can pretty much
play anything we can just grab the rook
on b1 for example so i mean
there's that and if we try something
like bishop to d2 to try and guard it
this way we're just going to capture on
d4 and now there's a double attack here
we're gonna
capture it and that's uh pretty much it
uh if you move the knight let's say
knight to the e2
again we don't care we can just capture
here with check and after everything
gets traded off we can just pick up the
rook here on b1 then move the bishop
promote the pawn and
we have too much material so after
bishop to b4
artemi of uh after our time we played
this and resigned the game and
what an amazing victory with the black
pieces i mean now people
i think the karo khan will will you know
be played by everyone after after they
see this game
so you know be be careful for that if
you play you know online
uh you know be ready for the carl khan
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh
really really an awesome one uh i would
like to thank david kimura nigel
holloway leandra moderson
happy birthday ccp and constantino buchi
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing with the coverage of these
incredible games
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day